Traductor: Luisa Salomón
"No me tomes fotos", "ignora mis cejas"
"que no salga mi estómago",
"mejor espera a que adelgace,
es que odio como me veo."
"¿Por qué nunca salgo bien?",
"¿Por qué no me veo como esa modelo o esa actriz?"
¿Se les hacen conocidas algunas de estas frases?
Suelen pasar desapercibidas,
incluso inofensivas.
Recuerden si las han escuchado
en si mismos o en otra persona,
tomen un segundo y piensen si las han visto como broma o enojo.
"¡Borra eso!, ¡no me pongas la cámara!"
Nosotros como consumidores estamos muy
acostumbrados a la influencia del marketing
como el cine, la fotografía y los medios de comunicación
nos han saturado con un ya muy conocido estándar de belleza,
un irreal estándar de belleza
y esto cambia la perspectiva de uno mismo.
Pero la fotografía siendo uno
de los mayores influyentes
de esta perspectiva, ha afectado a las personas de manera negativa.
¿Podemos revertirlo y usarlo a nuestro favor?,
¿puede la fotografía ser una herramienta que nos ayude
a revalonarnos, resignificarnos a nosotros mismos?
Sí, sí puede.
Cuando me encontraba en la universidad, un maestro nos pidió
de tarea fotografiar gente que no conociéramos
y a falta de confianza y exceso de vergüenza, muchos compañeros
alegamos necesitar gente que se viera bien ante la cámara, es decir,
modelos.
Mi maestro dijo algo: "Un buen fotógrafo puede hacer
que cualquier persona se vea bien y cualquier persona
puede tener un buen retrato".
Y aunque sé que fue un descuido de sabiduría de mi maestro
y lo que realmente quería decir era: "No sean flojos
o cobardes y hagan su tarea".
Me marcó, me definió como fotógrafo.
En la misma época, un maestro de danza me pidió fotografiar
a sus alumnos de primaria, chicos entre seis y doce años.
Este fue un momento decisivo, fue mi momento de:
"¡Ajá!, oh, rayos".
Lo que me lleva ahora a hablar con ustedes,
chicos de quinto y sexto de primaria,
¿alguno de ustedes recuerda su primer amor a esta edad?
A esta edad, cuando las niñas están muertas por Justin Bieber
comenzamos a darnos una idea de realmente como debemos vernos
para ser gustados y las burlas y los ataques por tener rasgos
que no estén a la par, rasgos físicos que sobresalgan
o que simplemente un día comenzaron a ser negativos.
Pero, ¿qué provoca esto?
Eso provoca.
Pero, ¿qué pasa antes de que
tengamos una idea
de todo este canon de belleza?
Cuando los fotografié, veía tantas emociones, tantos sentimientos,
los veías realmente ligeros, sin problemas,
no tenían este peso.
Pero cuando fotografié a los chicos de quinto y sexto.
Uno de ellos literalmente jaló
a su compañero para ocultarse
a si mismo.
Se negaron tan bruscamente a ser vistos, veías timidez, pena,
vergüenza, miedo, incluso enojo. Se negaron tanto a ser vistos.
¿Qué diferente, verdad?
¿Ustedes se han sentido así alguna vez?
Es triste, ¿verdad?
¿Pero irreversible? No.
Yo lo fotografié el día de su boda, y él, en el día más importante
de su vida, donde yo veía una hermosa escena y una
linda fotografía, sólo me dijo:
"Por favor, no fotografíes
mi lado izquierdo".
Él estando joven sufrió, un accidente automovilístico
que dejó una cicatriz debajo del mentón.
La infancia y la juventud pueden ser muy difíciles, pero cuando
tienes un rasgo que sobresale, algunos sabemos que aún más.
Yo dejé de hablar, toda la primaria no hablé por un problema
de habla. Incluso ahora lo tengo, una peculiar dicción.
¿Ustedes recuerdan algo por lo que los hayan molestado
y se sientan incómodos ahora?
Cuando creces, ya no quieres verte como Justin Bieber
pero no te sientes cómodo
contigo mismo, no te sientes
lo suficientemente atractivo
o guapo y comienzas a pasar
de ocultarte en las fotos a pedir que no las tomen y esto es un
problema, porque estas ideas empiezan a pesar, empiezas a
dudar, dudar de ti y esta duda pronto se vuelve una falsa certeza
de como te percibes a ti mismo.
Pero, ¿qué podemos hacer?
La fotografía es una herramienta poderosa que puede ayudarnos
a salvar vidas hoy mismo; al
año, 800,000 personas
se suicidan, es la segunda
causa de muerte
entre chicos de 16 a 29 años,
la principal razón es depresión
y baja autoestima.
El darnos cuenta de esto, es
algo que puede literalmente
salvar vidas, mejorar la calidad de vida.
Él es Valentín y esa es su cicatriz.
No se trata de ocultar tus defectos sino de mostrarlos, saber
que son tuyos y sentirte cómodo, incluso reírte de ellos y bromear.
Busqué personas que se sintieran mal consigo mismas, que tuvieran
muchos problemas con su imagen, que hayan sufrido de burlas o de
problemas cuando eran jóvenes.
Guiando la sesión y mostrándoles como es que ellos realmente
se pueden ver a través de la lente, con otros ojos, sin retoques,
sin peso, ligeros, enseñándoles lenguaje corporal y como es
que ellos se ven bien en unas fotos y en otras no, buscando
principalmente comodidad y retratarla.
¿Han notado que una sonrisa forzada se nota y también mínimos
rasgos de tensión hacen que una persona se vea totalmente distinta
de una foto a otra?
Como personas notamos el lenguaje corporal.
Estas sesiones y en estas entrevistas, estas personas
confiaron en mí, me dijeron: "Odio mi nariz de bruja,
no me gustan las fotos porque estoy gordo y realmente
no me gusta hablar de ello,
odio mis cejas de azotador,
o no me gusta sonreír porque mi boca es grotesca.
Rasgos que los afectaron y les provocaron un peso al día a día.
Pero,
con una guía, con unas pocas fotos, una sesión, logramos ver
resultados desde el día uno.
Estas personas incluso se negaron a sonreír.
Logramos que se revaloraran, se resignificaran.
La fotografía es una herramienta poderosa y podemos utilizar
de esta manera una de las herramientas más abundantes
del mundo, para ayudar
y si logramos esto con una sesión, sin retoques, sin trucos,
mostrándoles como son ellos con ligereza.
¿Qué pasara, si nos damos la oportunidad a nosotros mismos
de vernos como realmente somos?
Porque eso es, somos... y ya.
Y eso, está absolutamente bien.
Gracias.
Subtítulos: Marien Baranda Pacheco
TEDxZamoraPark 2017